good morning Hank it's Tuesday what do I
have in common with a Catholic priest
I just feel naked without my collar it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
just the one question today I'm a
college freshman how do I figure out
what the hell to do with my life Hank we
got some version of this question almost
every day but to answer the question I
have to begin by disagreeing with it the
whole what do I do with my life question
implies that adulthood is this
monolithic creature that like you
acquire your job and your spouse and
then you just ride it out until times
winged chariot shows up I thought this
when I was younger too and it's not our
fault because how does every single
happily-ever-after movie and with
finding your one true love and kissing
them occasionally marrying them at the
very latest having a child with them 95%
of romantic stories end with partners
committing to each other because
everything after that is just the blank
terrifying morass of adulthood this
monotonous grind in which the only real
excitement in your life is occasionally
finding a truly ripe avocado at the
grocery store now listen Hank I'm not
gonna lie to you I get very excited when
I find it truly ripe avocado at the
grocery store but it's not the only
excitement in my life and let me submit
that one of the reasons you're so
terrified about figuring out what you're
gonna do with your life is that you
think you're only gonna be able to do
one thing like if someone told you that
in four years you were going to have to
pick one musical note to listen to for
the rest of your life you would spend a
lot of time being super anxious about
which note to pick and the various total
qualities of different notes but that's
not what life is like you will always be
figuring out what to do with your life
and you'll get to do lots of different
things and your decisions will be unmade
by circumstance like your wife gets a
job in Kuala Lumpur you're staring at
the night sky one night and decide you
want to get a PhD in astrophysics or
your uncle dies and there's no one to
take over his junk yard or your little
brother starts a freakin video
conference just like your life now
adulthood will have all this tension
between idealism and practicality and
you'll have to balance competing desires
I mean give yourself some credit even if
you're 14 or 15 you're already kind of
doing adulthood but I think what
actually scared me about choosing
whether to go to school and what to
study was that each time I made a
decision my options narrowed right like
if you're pre-med you're probably not
gonna be a software designer if you
study archaeology you're probably not
going to become an electrical engineer
and there is something a little
terrifying about the narrowing of those
possibilities because you become aware
that they will continue to narrow
until you are dead and that sucks but
here's the other thing if you don't make
decisions the options still narrow and
you don't have to do just one thing you
can be an electrical engineer who
volunteers on archaeological digs
William Carlos Williams was both a poet
and a doctor Julia Child aside from
being an extraordinary chef was also a
freakin spy for the United States I mean
Hank if you told my college self that
I'd one day be a novelist with the side
gig putting my mustachioed face on the
torsos of strangers I would have been
duly surprised and you studied organic
fracking chemistry before writing songs
about Harry Potter so here's my advice
study broadly and without fear we're in
a language if you can because that will
make your life more interesting read a
little bit every day but most
importantly try to surround yourself
with people you like and make cool stuff
with them in the end at least in my
experience what you do isn't going to be
nearly as interesting or important as
who you do it with I think that's why I
always say that the best decision we
made as video bloggers was also the
first decision to collaborate with each
other now that sounds perilously close
to me saying that I love my brother so I
need to cut the sentiment a little bit I
need to think of something like they
don't just be like his you have a stupid
face or something that's good Hank you
have a stupid face I'll see you on
Friday